le stis le service départemental
d'incendié et de secours est financé à
hauteur d'un peu plus de 28 millions
d'euros
la ctm y apporte 18 millions soit 64 %
du budget de fonctionnement
l'enveloppé globale des contributions
des communes est un peu plus de 10
millions d'euros
sur cette somme les pins de la ville du
lamentin et de fort de france sont très
significatives fort de france qui avait
été pointée du doigt par le président du
stis au début du mouvement de grève des
sapeurs pompiers
nous avons une grosse commune celle de
fondeurs russes qui ne peut plus à
contribution
résultat ça accueillait cross d'un autre
budget nous avions beaucoup de voix tant
que nous avons rattrapé que nous avons
comblé aujourd'hui nous avons quelques
mois de potence ou 2018 et nous sommes
en train de faire les premiers mandats
pour 2019
ça c'est une réalité deuxièmement on a
toujours fonctionné avec les 10
lorsqu'ils ont lorsqu'ils envisagent ils
entrevoient des difficultés de
trésorerie qui viennent de façon à ce
que nous on regarde comment on va
pouvoir faire un 2e mandat permettant
aux indices de pouvoir tenir ce qui
manifestement le mois dernier n'a pas
été fait autres communes le lorrain en
2016 le maire justin pamphile avait
reconnu son incapacité à régler sa
quote-part
aujourd'hui le discours est tout autre
aujourd'hui nous avons qui était la
nôtre nous avons commencé nous avons
signé une convention donc avec le lycée
nous versons en fait tous les mois 12e
de ce qui correspond à la cotisation due
par la ville c'est à dire 16 1000 euros
chaque mois depuis le début de l'année
la ville doit verser un total d'un peu
plus de 200 2000 euros il y à de gros
retards mais aussi selon ces mères un
problème dans la répartition des moutons
des cotisations nous avions du mal à
comprendre comment la boue qui fait par
exemple ou une villes de même strate
il y en a une qui paie 200 2000 euros
c'était notre cas et puis avait une
autre qui était éventuellement à 140 ou
150 dons qu'il y avait des différences
tels que nous ne comprenions pas répond
temps nous étions sous les même strate
de population sa fille d'un ami
de très nombreuses années que la ville
de fort de france réclament un
équilibrage des contributions ça fait
l'objet d'une étude qui a été validée
présenter un début de mise en
application qui a été interrompue depuis
2010 2016 donc à partir de là la ville
de fort de france a décidé de poursuivre
son action pour revenir une contribution
plus nous équitable on nous réclamait 4
millions 7 alors que l'étude établit que
la contribution juste de fond de france
serait autour de 2 millions de
aujourd'hui nous versons trois millions
sept d'heures de contribution c'est à
dire plus de 1 million et demi d'euros
par an de trop mais le stis reste sous
dotées 28 millions d'euros
c'est trop peu alors que faire belfort
birota s'interroge
il faut donc trouver de nouvelles
sources de financement il faut chercher
au niveau des opci les communautés
d'agglo et puis surtout je n'ai de cesse
de le répéter et c'est un petit peu
l'approché actuelle allait vers la
rochelle d'un fonds européen le 10 de la
réunion le fait très bien
en attendant de trouver une solution
pérenne les pompiers restent mobilisés
aujourd'hui ils crient au secours
[Musique]